something already
yeah he's just like looking around like
he there's something
wrong smoothie
he forgot a smoothie again maybe again
yeah can someone get me a smoothie
yeah not a good sign when you're already
feeling a bit flustered a bit disturbed
and the game has only just started
you might as well just make your move
hands just get through the opening
unleash your preparation and then start
thinking
both
very strange yeah very strange spending
time and need that time for later yeah
this position
you should obviously know about yeah
anish will be feeling confident the
longer that hans thinks right now yeah
and i mean the arbiter is in the room if
there was something
she would be over there immediately so
maybe it's just is it the position it's
the situation like
this doesn't look this is strange the
most uh well-known positions in chess i
guess in the opening at least
black has a bunch of moves here you can
choose from three four five very logical
very common moves
uh it can't be chess reasons that are
making hands slow down now
is the mouse frozen is the screen frozen
i think he'd be gesturing more wouldn't
he if there's something completely wrong
maybe he's just picking his music you
know maybe he's thinking this is a big
game i can't lose what song do i need to
listen to some energy he doesn't learn
as pumped up as we're used to seeing no
right because he can't lose this game
okay
here we have it he's off yeah and he's
picked up the b pawn and this opening is
called queens indian and anish also
reacts in the most principled way which
is to develop the light squared bishop
yeah so very standard stuff the reason i
guess it's called the queen's indian
it's on the queen side and you're
fianchettoing a bishop normally these
types of indian openings the king's
indian is fee and catering the bishop on
the other flank
of the board
uh meanwhile a bunch of moves here that
white can choose
i know this is the one i play actually i
think there's very good chance of
getting advantage this this rookie one
currently with the theory
and um i'm just trying to think the
trendy move now is it a3
i think a3 might be the
sort of current move to play even
because uh
you know you're kind of asking yeah he's
played at a3 so
yeah just basically black's move the
night where you're gonna move that
knight next i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna shut it down and wait and see how
you're gonna develop and if black wants
to go really solid he can move the pawn
in front of the queen two squares but um
there's a lot of ways black can go wrong
here
if you move the well i mean the pawn
next to that one two squares what's he
gonna go for just shuffles his queen
across one square okay this is just kind
of waiting moves from waiting passive
i think i should interest i had this in
break of it that's why i remember just
doing a bit of preparation i remember it
looked just really nice variation
for uh for white
um
it's just that pawn center you have a
bit more space yeah and you might be at
okay the one thing that white generally
avoids doing in these positions is going
knight c free too early um
which we can show i don't know if it's a
move now because you want to avoid
exchanging pieces and if you move the
knight out now it allows black to play
his knight in
and the exchange of pieces makes black's
position a bit more comfortable because
he's more cramped
and that's that's why the knight stays
at home so there's many ways that white
can try and prove his position
without moving that knight you can maybe
move the queen i mean you can even you
can even think about some you know pawn
sacrifices but i think you know
uh there's even moving the queen side
pawn two squares doesn't look stupid to
me very dancing here it does i mean that
black knight on the side of the board
looks looks kind of ridiculous right
good that's like one of the issues with
this system
yeah one of the things i did want to
point out for for white that is uh if
black hadn't played that queen move and
instead had actually tried to challenge
the center
with a
c7 c5 that's why i had a break of it
eventually yeah did you do it did you go
for it simon just played b5 is just a
very good move where white's just
clearly better basically i think i need
to ask ivanka so i'm all pushy's pawn to
this square exactly the opportunity i
love getting my pawn there but this is
the move i wanted to highlight because
after pawn takes born you can actually
you move the yeah
and you don't even sacrifice the pawn
here that's the thing it's not even a
sacrifice
can you get your knight to this this
gorgeous square then black's king and
i i had this and you know i had this and
my opponent i think played knight e4 but
this is a very nice line for white
basically so
um but i avoided this yeah and queen c8
david it seems a bit passive yeah i mean
what would you play here i mean b4 looks
so logical right i mean that would
probably be very tempting yeah there
might be other decent options i was
thinking okay so he has played this i i
was surprised by that lightly attempted
to suggest this as well i know uh black
always meets this with the thread of a
knight exchange but um this is very
similar to other lines anyway uh where
kind of black's knight is still back in
its starting square black's queen is
still on its starting square the other
main line and normally whitehead puts
his bishop on this square and he's not
afraid of giving up the two bishops
so if there's a night trade white bishop
sounds great on this square
if the knight captures the bishop
instead then at least now white is ready
to throw all the pawns forward in the
center
and
yes it's it's a slightly different take
on one of the main lines at least
so i i'm assuming this is what giri
wants to do the one thing you
don't necessarily want to do is for
example if you make a move uh you don't
want to allow these double pawns because
they are potentially weak later in the
game
especially in an end game
so i think gary especially having
allowed this potential knight exchange i
think he's just going to stop
that from happening either by moving his
bishop forward or by maybe moving his
queen
to protect his knight
the other thing i wanted to mention is
that after knight takes to save white
word play knight takes night
um bishop takes knight it's so difficult
to dislodge that bishop from this
beautiful square without offering a
trade of your own bishops
so
that's why i mean white generally holds
back because
it wasn't a threat for black snite to go
in there
when when you had the knight on its
starting square that wasn't something
you have to worry about but
as david says you know you can't play
this line it's just uh it's just maybe
there's another useful move that you can
do even h4 has been played by sigisian i
think in this kind of position
um music players it's very trendy to
push the ball here yeah just to support
some jumps with your knight on the
king's side just ask you know blackboard
what are you going to do next yeah
it's basically a fight for this central
square if white can push his pawn
forward he's doing great he has three
great pawns in the center of the board
uh if black can stop that as he's doing
right now by blockading this square then
he tends to be doing okay so evaluation
bar likes white i think we all would
choose white here but it's just a fight
for this uh central outpost and he does
indeed play the typical type of move
putting his bishop i'm impressed with
the i'm impressed with hans being on
more than 14 minutes on the clock after
spending what was it one and a half
minutes on the first move he must have
uh planned something is he definitely in
his opening prep here
i think well i'll just check the
database here and he actually had a game
in this particular variation
uh in
2021
and that game actually continued with
white trading nights so he is familiar
hans is certainly familiar with this
particular position and the and the
results here hands one of course is that
an online blitz game
i
it's difficult for me to see okay
yeah because i know a lot of online
blitz games now go on the database and
uh it's maybe something that han's
played once or twice in his life but
maybe not having put too much work into
it at least when i've played this
opening as black it's just to kind of
survive the opening it's not necessarily
because you want to equalize immediately
you just want to keep pieces on the
board you want to kind of pose these
questions to white how are you going to
occupy the center
uh okay it looks like white's getting
everything he wants
and now big question what does black do
with his knight in the center of the
board but do you then think david
spending that one and a half minutes on
the first move he was thinking back to
that game that he won maybe and trying
to recall
how he won it yeah maybe it was well
just
uh i know he had a bit of a break before
this game but maybe he was undecided do
you play for a win with black do you
just keep it solid solid with black now
and then try and win with white in the
next game
um i guess it's not kind of the most
aggressive winning attempt but this type
of opening it is played by players who
are quite ambitious as black who want to
just maintain the tension
and uh yeah it's just a typical position
now this last move simon you're like
that maybe as a dutch player i do like
it yeah yeah i mean i i love pushing
this pawn when i got the black pieces
but i just really don't like black's
knight on the you know we have this
saying on the side of the board the
knights in the room are dim nights on
the side fall off i mean what there's
loads loads of sayings about that night
if i can move that night
back i'd probably be tempted to move it
back now actually and just try to get it
towards the center because uh otherwise
it's doing nothing you know
but
if i can move it like across to f6 for
example
okay but still i mean this these are all
common moves that black's playing here
and at least black's got the central
square right in the middle you know
controlling the middle order board
you're right i mean black's queen is
slightly misplaced maybe black's knight
on the edge uh will fall off the hedge
yeah and fall off the hedge i don't know
yeah that's good but uh full of the
ledge full of the ledge yeah
well okay now it's a
critical moment in the game because
anish just pushed forward with his pawn
in the center and now all the connection
that black had with the knight on e4
it's been broken
um to me this is very thematic this
looks good but i guess you have to now
start to crunch the numbers and see
whether it's actually a good idea or not
yeah and uh this kind of a typical pawn
push you want to gain space you want to
clamp down on squares you want to block
out black's light squared bishop but
yeah i'm slightly surprised gary played
it so quickly because it does make sense
as you mentioned that of some of black's
pieces black's knight on the edge
it has a way off that ledge
but uh okay
hands this is a critical moment so he
should slow down now this is where you
should spend your time not necessarily
on move three um
yeah he'll be calculating already and
this is the only match that can be
decided in this round three if anish
wins it he will win the match it's not a
must-win situation for hans but he has
to win either this one or the next game
to take it to tie breaks in the other
matches magnus carlsen and liam lee two
draws they are tied after two games
magnus now sitting there with the white
pieces and i bet he is uh trying to find
a way to win this game three and uh liam
leia
yeah probably will be a happy and be
happy with a draw with the black pieces
and uh fighting for a win in game four
pragnanda and levon aronian also two
jaws they're also
tied prague with the white pieces here
thinking hard and it's the bar
already all the way over to the side
yeah i mean i just took a peek over at
that game there's two things i want to
mention one
that aronian chosen opening the grunfeld
defense that he's not a specialist in
but prague is known as the grunfeld
slayer he wins nearly every game as
white in that opening
i've seen him win dozens in great style
as well and the second thing i want to
point out everyone has just fallen into
an opening trap it's maybe not the most
well-known one but prague is deep in his
preparation aronian i think it's his
move right now uh but look at him he's
just sitting back thinking
what have i done am i really in trouble
now or maybe he doesn't even realize how
much trouble he's in but yeah the
computer thinks the white is already
winning after what is it about 12 13
moves whoa
uh prague if he takes that opportunity
continues his good form against the
grunfeld defense
then iranian is going to be in big
trouble
huge trouble for levon aronian early in
game
three wow we'll keep a close eye on that
young christopher duda and all the rest
of russia they have uh won one game each
and are tied their game three will start
shortly or has started just started
probably
yep they're racing to catch up yeah this
yeah
he won the first game but he lost the
second so what will happen in game three
between uh these two but we're following
giri and nima because this can be
decided in this round three
and the bar i have to say it's uh way
over to initial side right now yeah i
don't know about you guys but i just
love what's happened for the white side
i'm a bit worried now about prague about
not prague
neiman's chances sorry just because
a couple of things have gone wrong
firstly there's a nasty pin white's
bishop on the same diagonal as the black
queen
and the center will open to white's
favors also black's knight still on the
edge of the board if he doesn't move it
now white will push the b pawn forward
and lock it out of the game
it looks horrible it does look like
bishop is well misplaced totally uh
two pieces that aren't working and
i mean it also looks like
those pawns on the right side are just
going to start falling apart and black's
king is also going to be vulnerable
yeah i mean it's i mean you're just
winning a pawn i mean generally i'm a
big fan of
black's pawns you know when you get them
like that the one in front of the bishop
the one next to the bishop i like having
those pawns
they got a lot of potential but only
when you can do something with them
and they're just gonna they're just
gonna drop here and look at black's
pieces on the queen side it's not just
that knight it's the bishop as well
right the bishop is just looking at a
brick wall uh it's not doing anything at
all there's so many problems with
black's position here yeah i guess his
idea after pawn takes pawn is to slide
his bishop back he's okay he's just done
this so at least he's improving one of
those bad pieces simon but you're right
i mean it just looks horrible um at
least he has a pin on this diagonal so
he's pawned down temporarily but
eventually he wants to win this pinned
pawn back white can't play pawn takes
pawn for example because his bishop
would fall
so two moves immediately comes to mind
what is kerry about to play here he's
not moving on his screen yet but two
moves come to mind for me one you
actually defend the pinned piece uh for
example with your king next move you're
just hinting that maybe you'll jump out
the way capture a pawn
uh if you
kind of win upon if you can somehow win
that pawn and establish your knight on
this beautiful outpost in the center
you're just winning immediately so this
would maybe be the most ambitious move
in the position um if i mean if that
doesn't work or if it doesn't appeal to
step your king forward then another idea
at some point would be to step this pawn
forward and lock out this knight on the
edge i mean it's just such a bad piece
and one bad piece as we know makes a
position bad yeah
looks great for white but
anish needs one or two accurate moves
yeah and both those moves were on my
radar i must say i'm such a materialist
i was drawn to defending the bishop and
trying to get away with grabbing as many
pawns as i can
but yeah this just looks great yeah i
guess black's idea maybe is to kind of
reinstate the pin just
bring the queen forward meaning that
white still is tied down on this
diagonal
i mean i'm just clutching at straws here
for neiman i mean you need to keep the
game alive somehow
but uh anish he's even more
materialistic than us ivanka
instead of pushing his king forward he
actually ruins his own pawn structure he
pushes his pawn forward defending his
own pawn
and
after a capture a trade here white just
has this stronghold
i mean it's more about this square in
the centre of the board for one of the
two white knights both knights can
occupy it and it's just a glorious
square wow white's king is just going to
shuffle to the corner where it's
completely safe and
looking good for gary looking good for
anish uh geary now uh david as everyone
knows he is our very own individual gold
medalist for from the olympiad in
chennai and the chess 24 team actually
has another medalist from the olympia
tanya commentating on another stream she
took the individual bronze medal in
chennai and she's actually also in
miami's weather
she is i'm actually going to have to
speak quite low right now because i'm on
her terrace and she is doing the
commentary on the gm feed together with
peter leko but have a look at this let's
let's actually let me lower my voice
and and show you what is one of my
favorite
shows
shoots that we can actually get here
because right here behind me
we have tanya doing the commentary
and she tends to get extremely excited
when she's doing it she stands up she is
yelling and she goes excited
[Music]
hey
and it would be a little chance for us
to move somewhere but on the other hand
one feels like you know you want to look
at this peter we've got company here
we're joined by the oslo studio hey guys
wow
he's the man behind all those interviews
by the way chat wants to know we want to
know do we get another hands interview
today we're hoping so definitely so i
guess i'm talking to both broadcasts
right now but any hans interview is
bound for a good day but we want to see
our top commentators sitting here in her
right element
well this is what it looks like so we've
got our chat
and our game window here and this is our
broadcast and a very big moment here
because love looks like he's in big big
trouble he's managed to get his queen
trapped on a5 uh we're trying to find
the right way ahead for prague here
uh
this is a big game swear
as you can see they are now following
also the left game who is in big trouble
[Music]
absolutely
chess 24 got you all covered if you are
a grandmaster and want to deep into the
positions with a lot of notations then
tanya and peter got you covered in this
one in this studio we're taking it down
a little bit
beginners like me we need the slower
approach to the game and deep dive into
the position without too many notations
at least anish giri bar over to his side
if he wins this game he will win his
first match
is it getting closer david he's getting
closer i'm not liking his clock time
manish gary it looks like he's a bit
hesitant maybe
just the nerves of having struggled in
this tournament
just getting closer to the finishing
line slowing him down slightly that's
what i do at least when i'm on the verge
of a big victory i get nervous i tense
up uh but yeah on the board he's doing
all the things right maybe now is the
time to lock out that black knight from
the game
um you could also make an argument for
white's rook just sliding across to the
open g file
white knight at some point wants to
occupy that beautiful outpost on e4 that
we highlighted a moment ago
looks great but uh yeah what do you guys
think i i think that this is great for
white i mean my opinion really hasn't
changed i mean i really do love your
plan of just looking at the black knight
on asics and just saying what you're
gonna do about that piece
and
then getting on with the ideas you
mentioned as well put in the rook to
open line introducing the knights into
the game i mean this just looks like
he can
like this almost looks like the position
can play itself actually ah spoiled for
choice but that is not good for the
clock
down under six minutes now when you have
too many options it's easy to kind of
just mull them over overthink them uh
giri just has to trust his instincts
he's got such good instincts uh one of
the most talented youngsters that i've
ever faced gary and yeah he just needs
to push a pawn or bring his knight to
the center switch his rook over they're
all strong why not just play one of them
instantly save the time for later is he
a very emotional player so if he he does
have a few bad results it will affect
his play yeah he's good at keeping kind
of a
kind of happy facade like uh joking
he's got quite a bright disposition in
general quite a positive guy but then
yeah occasionally
um things do affect him i think which is
natural but any trust but i always get
the feeling with a niche that he can
pick himself up yeah you know there's a
few people who just when they
hit the floor you know it's very
difficult for them just to build
themselves to big themselves back up
again but anish somehow you know
it feels like he gives himself maybe
five minutes of feeling like
sadness and very depressed and then he's
like okay right move on to the next game
yeah but i mean we we do see that he
doesn't quite clear the emotions on the
board because we see certain things like
for instance here he's taking his time
he's perhaps feeling some tension
because he's gone
through many many many games without
winning and that creates some kind of
internal pressure
and uh when the wind happens again when
he wins this match then he will just be
able to
just affect that domino yeah you know
just like the shoulders can relax and
the tension can just just dissipate yeah
and he never goes on long losing streaks
gary like other players when they tilt
they'll lose many games in a row uh for
gary it's just the killer instincts the
first thing that disappears
so he's still an amazing player it's
just can't finish things off so maybe
some drawing streaks here and there but
yeah yeah he's coming back in this game
in this day and he goes for another plan
which is just to relocate the knight
over to the right side of the board
and whilst it's hans's turn to
figure out what to do we do have a
selfie competition where we're asking
you guys at home to tweet a selfie that
will impress our david howell and the
winner will get david's course grind
like a grandmaster that he did with
magnus carlsen it's amazing price and
renjith of pillay says he's watching
from india watching the live chess and
learning some french defense even at
midnight that's dedication david does
that impress you yeah anything i mean
studying chess after midnight that's the
best time that's when it really soaks in
i recommend you know running a bath
lying there oh so watching a chassis
course or
you did say at the olympiad you're
having uh two hour baths every day every
night every night and i was like oh
that's not fail you're not a bit wrinkly
i was it was like a old grape
prune just yes
what were you doing meditating i was
chatting to friends on the phone i mean
my laptop was dead so i didn't have i
couldn't prepare chess i was just
sitting there sometimes with the book um
yeah yeah just loving it i also got my
best run of chess was in the bath as
well
um
what was this story so
well
when i was younger i i just had a puzzle
book
like a chess puzzle book start finding
checkmate and i used to just have a bath
every day and i just try to do some
puzzles on the path so after the period
of like three months i've done the book
and my rating shot up so actually yeah
from doing half an hour in the bath
every day i became much better much
better player so
baths it's the way
forward we are trying to solve this game
and it's that simple have a bath every
day learning a path yeah
i need the water
did you did you learn from the path word
of warning i tried this technique once i
fell asleep the book fell into daughter
so yeah not for everyone um bathtubs
aren't easy to come by unfortunately
yeah that's true
but uh okay meanwhile the position has
changed slightly and okay the evaluation
bar not liking what anish has done
i still think it's okay for white but
look at that knight next to the white
king that is one passive piece and he
shouldn't be having any passive pieces
right now initially not sure about this
position yeah i know you guys i know
you're both very confident about uh
anisha's chances but i really didn't
like his g4 and
he seemed a bit funny i mean i i i don't
know i mean i i don't mind black hair at
all yeah i liked his g4 anish but i
don't like what he's done with his two
nights white's knights are passive now
and han's trying to break out well he's
gone far too passive i mean just white's
king is is a little bit loose now
definitely
black's bishop
dark square bishop is beautiful he's got
an open g file it is it's it's dangerous
i think for for aneesha is he even
better yeah good question i'm not even
sure he's better now i mean he's a pawn
up yeah but what can he do he's got to
try to get through this bishop at some
point and i i don't know if he can do
that this bishop right yeah yeah it
looks like on his screen anish he was
about to bring his rook over but he's
overthinking he's not trusting his
instincts he was about to play it within
a couple of seconds and now uh 30 40
seconds later he still hasn't made this
move you mentioned getting past this
bishop is his idea for example after a
pawn capture
is he going to sacrifice maybe at some
point to try and break through
for example okay he has played this move
i guess and another idea might be to
slide the queen across to this diagonal
and here it works extra well because
you're hitting the knight in the process
and after the knight is defended you
could for example just capture this
bishop and due to this pin black can't
take back you in a piece so still some
ideas some tricks anisha has up his
sleeve
and of course hans won't fall into that
kind of uh
it's not very well disguised that trick
hans will spot that and
he runs away with the bishop hans is
playing
recklessly fast i would say he actually
played really well he's outplayed giri
since that disastrous opening for black
but
why play this move so quickly i mean
there are alternatives you could start
kind of doubling up your rooks on this
file that was his best piece i mean
we're just talking how strong the bishop
is and he's just moved it away from the
best square so uh i mean it might be
okay because you can improve your other
pieces but it's not really what you want
to do and on the other hand the niche is
closing up on the queen side which is
also a little bit strange i think now
it's all going to switch to the king
side where both of the kings are sitting
right now i like hansa's potential plan
of maybe bringing his knight to this
square
if he can park his knight on this square
he's going to kick away the white rook
from its outpost and all the pieces will
gravitate towards that
white king meanwhile anish he's
i don't know really what he's doing with
this kind of pyramid of pieces but
uh it looks
nice-ish
aesthetically i'm not sure whether it's
effective the night is coming round
meanwhile to try and kick away this
white rook
hans hanzo's playing so quickly though
so quickly too quickly if anything yeah
i i feel like the position is incredibly
complicated and uh hands is just belting
out the moves second after second
and there are ideas such as taking this
pawn i'm not sure whether that works or
not but hans should at least be spending
a second calculating uh instead anish
just gets rid of the black knight
i guess hans is going for just a
blockade on on the dark squares now i
mean he is i i thought he could maybe
push for a little bit more uh than than
this kind of thing where he's just
trying to stop and each getting through
anywhere yeah
with the queen yeah
yeah i mean it still still
seems okay for black much better than it
was that's for sure um
but
again it's a strange game this one i
think a very strange game yeah strange
stuff happening aneesh trying to take
all the risk out of the position again
whether that's reducing his own winning
chances who knows but
aneesh definitely hates risk in this
tournament and he's just trying to trade
off all the remaining rooks han says
nope i'm going to go the other way hans
wants it looks silly but he wants to
open up i wouldn't be able to predict
many moves in this game sometimes you
know you can play predict the move and
just i'm struggling to predict what
they're going to play next i think we
would have predicted about ten percent
of the moves
and those were just the opening moves
okay knight e2 is he going to try to get
a knight to the center that makes the
most sense to me but then then black can
break on on the queen side so yeah but i
mean yeah that night not doing anything
let's get it over would would be uh you
know beautiful square in the middle of
the board that dave is highlighted there
yeah um let's talk to your pieces
white's knight is the worst piece yeah
and prove it no he improves his bishop
instead didn't predict that one okay
a6 can we get one prediction right is he
going to push the pawn in front of the
rook i predict hands will move in less
than 30 seconds i don't know what move
it okay come on you've got to predict
yeah i agree i think i mean the only
justification for putting blacks back in
the corner is to push the ball in front
of it open up that rope so will we get
this right i think he's going to
actually move his queen to the f4 square
okay
less seconds 10 seconds
i know you might even get that
prediction i didn't even get that
first time in the last 10 moves he slows
down and it's the most simple decision
i'm sure they can hear us and they're
just like messing with us at the moment
but so um i made complicated moves uh
that require calculation in like three
seconds hands and then the one time he
has like a logical consistent plan he
slows you slow down no we got that wrong
as well
okay now let's see he's going to move
the rook yeah okay come on please just
get that right where though simon he's
definitely moving his rook this doesn't
ask me difficult questions
to pin the bishop let's go for that i'm
going to go for that okay he's got to
pin the bishop of his rook surely come
on i'm going to slide one square to the
right i'll say it slide one square up
yeah yeah i think i think up the board
it's got to go to one of those two
squares actually i don't think it's
going to go up the board i think that
might be oh okay
okay maybe i should actually
slide do you think to the left
yeah i mean pinning the bishop seems
natural yeah you're right i don't know i
mean like yeah
maybe
i don't know somehow i'm a bit worried
that the rook is not doing that much i
mean he's not he's better yeah okay
let's just say just pin pin the bishop
pin the bishop you've got two minutes
two minutes worrying for gary yeah move
it feels like a hustle neiman he's yeah
it's like he's playing in i don't know
washington square park he's just
hustling geary on the clock he's like
come on man come on man i'm going to
play faster than you i'm going to play
trickier more unexpected moves than you
and it has been working oh david you got
it right
i don't know why it's not a good move
but we have the david victory dance so i
like it because we've got one move right
here can you show those moves again
david i missed it let's see later simon
i'll show you on the dance we haven't
recorded
because we do we did also record simon
dancing yes and you can put them
together
like a music video
maybe we can even show the viewers uh
what we put together of uh simon it was
written i think yesterday what was the
name of the dance the big box small box
yes
i don't know
again for us
no no but ivanka you know the moves now
come on your vancouver can you do the
big box small box i don't remember it
simon
big threat on the position though
there is a big threat
and
hans has to do something about this the
rook was threatening to come to the g8
square this queen was undefended it's
actually a mistake from hans in this
position he pushed his queen forward one
square uh the white queen slid across
and the queen went back so hans has just
lost two moves
the threat as ivanka mentions for
example if black had pushed a pawn is to
jump out of the way discovered attack
this is a check throw your rook on the
fire in order to open up an attack and
win the black queen just gaining time
with that sacrifice so black's queen
actually went back
the move is very mysterious from hands
especially david i mean moving the dark
square bishop over to
that square why i don't i just you know
i'm not sure there's a one move threat
he was attacking his opponents rook he
made another move kind of one move
threat he attacked his opponents rook
yeah he went back he's just losing time
yeah it's as if he's literally in the
park playing blitz just hustling he's
making threats setting traps but gary's
spotting them
and uh okay now he goes back
now it's surely time soon for the white
knight to activate okay first the queen
comes out push the pawn now surely come
on you gotta you gotta
do something simon you're predicting
this one will we get another prediction
right
come on it's gotta be nice
you've gotta
but it's a good move because it
activates the light square bishop this
looks like a nice move i i approve
at least at least the bishop has a good
square it's coming into here
so right rook or queen are the targets
so gary he's getting ready to move his
queen out the way
that's gonna step it back so the rook
has a square to retreat to
gary i think he's feeling the pressure
you know i just something about gary's
play he clicked on a different square he
nearly made him not a mouse lip but a
blunder there and uh okay he chose a
good square for his queen a safe square
but
just just judging by those i mean i've
been there myself you know when i'm
clicking on squares and i'm like oh no
that's wrong and then i change my mind
that shows nerves
shouldn't it be click a piece move a
piece yeah
touch piece move yeah yeah i mean he
clicked on the queen it's just he was
going to put it on the g3 square
originally then he kind of maybe it was
just a misclick and what about this move
didn't predict it didn't predict it i
thought he was going to attack the rig
but okay it seems like a less aggressive
square than the one it could have moved
to and uh maybe anish
had that rook retreat in his mind and so
decided to play it i mean i i also
a bit baffled but maybe he has some
ideas of attacking the queen himself
i'm not sure why he's not pushing that
rook's pawn though i i i don't know i
mean if you could get the black rook
around the back now
you could think about winning this game
as black even i mean why not
i don't see why not if the black rook
can magically get into white's half of
the board then you know that's his plan
well let's move the queen in
that either no no no it's really hard to
predict it's attacking an important pawn
though the white sea pawn so on the same
line that the black queen's sitting on
it's under fire it's not that easy to
defend this is a good move i think
it's a similar idea to trying to get the
rook in max king can defend itself those
two black bishops actually are doing a
great job of covering any entry squares
white that white's rook or queen want to
use
yeah suddenly maybe the change of pace
as well gary he's been maneuvering
around uh improving suddenly he has to
take steps back
yeah maybe this change of pace will
affect him and okay i'm not sure whether
you should grab it but black's queen can
go and grab the white a3 pawn it looks
like it's the wrong side of the board
i'm not sure he'll want to do that but
it's kind of position where i would be
very tempted to move that pawn in the
center i'd be looking at it i mean bid
for freedom my rook might better come in
okay he hasn't done that but
it's the kind of move where you can if
you can jump to freedom get your bishop
you're brooking the game it's like you
know maybe word for sacrifice of one
pawn you know right simon just free up
this bishop instead the players are
racing ahead so he did grab this ball he
did get greedy
and now the white queen moved and he
came back
so his idea surely at some points to
break this side of the board open hands
but in the meantime can anish get any
action going towards the black king this
he would love to somehow just like you
said free up the bishop
i was gonna say this is the this is the
way forward right he's attacking the
black bishop he's hoping uh okay the
rook can't be captured by a pawn due to
a pin here he's hoping that there'll be
a capture and that suddenly he can
threaten checkmate breakthrough on the
light squares to that black king it's a
great move i mean i love that move
that's what we want to see from gary we
don't want to see him taking passive
decisions yeah yeah we love it but how
effective is it though maybe the black
rook can just come across
you like kill all the fun because now
white rook cannot take the black bishop
due to a nasty checkmate
the black rook defends the black queen
and the king is trapped maybe this is a
calm defense
in the current position what else you
don't want to move this bishop out the
way
i don't think you can really consider
taking this even if you can kind of
block any potential checkmates you'll
always kind of
get
punished on the light squares later
it's so scary right now for hands i
think this is the move that i would play
without too much thought i think just
try and trade off those rooks maybe
white just leaves it though maybe
uh white just doesn't react because
there's still a pin along this h file
suddenly the black king is the target
it's got very interesting this game now
i mean this position is uh is really
jumped to life with uh you know the
black king is in danger but that that
queen is right into white's guts there
causing some issues so if black can
unravel black could win this game wow
kenny unbravled i yeah i like david's
movies it's a nice in fact moved to
players he played that yeah no yeah he's
gone for it in fact
this and actually capturing the rook
were the only two ways for black to
survive this position yeah and uh here
can you guess what the computer's saying
it's like
zero 0.00 yeah of course yeah
stupid computer yeah
yeah so complicated okay the rooks are
off the board i don't think that's a
great sign for gary to be honest why is
he i mean he's going for the queen
exchange now and now the bar is shifting
sides yeah that's what i'm saying
it's a passive decision gary it seems
like when the clock ticks down his
instinct his nature is to just try and
draw just try to get the queens off
he is in the lead in the match so we can
understand it now but yeah i mean uh
he's missed opportunities opportunities
in the past due to this
in fairness it is understandable because
if we look at the whole momentum of the
game you know he was much better then he
was pawn up and then somehow or other
he's found himself defending this
position and then the instinct now is
okay i've lost control let's just trade
off let's just begin again
just kill the game he's begging for a
draw if the queen's come off the board
only black can ever win that game uh win
that position
maybe he will draw because white's is so
blocked white does have a knight which
can jump around and
cover all the holes but
i mean also there's an argument for
hands to keep the queens on the ball
because his queen is quite i mean quite
active you can put it in the corner
keeping the knight pinned
and try try for the maximum from the
position i mean i don't know what i do i
don't know if i'd exchange and just try
to play or maybe play for this a6 break
first again i'm a bit addicted to this
a6 break for some reason i really want
to change the ball structure on that
left side i would love to do that
because then the endings will be great
for me if i get the opportunity
to exchange queens in the future so but
he's kept i mean the simple option this
move this move was has been very
tempting for a while to free the dark
square bishop yeah and his idea as well
is to win white's pawn so it's not
actually a pawn sacrifice now this white
pawn in the middle on the e3 square is
gonna get gobbled up by black star squad
bishop on the next move black star score
bishop is going to take that pawn
the stretch has changed also look at the
center black's king has a path in the
dark on the dark squares into the middle
of the board
i fear for gary's life here maybe it's a
fortress but i think if white just moves
the king
it's going to be very hard for black to
do anything now maybe black's king kind
of goes all the way over to the left
side of the board he pushed that pawn
that you wanted simon and the black king
comes back
we're in for another long grind yeah
nice today i have to mention you guys we
have had two big results inside the
arena here in uh game threes magnus
carlsen just won game three against liam
let to take the lead in that match
putting liam in a must-win situation in
game four to take it to thai breaks and
pragnanda the other player online out of
nine points after the first three days
a win against levon aronian and that was
a quite quick one actually in game three
so levona roney and also must win
in game four to take it to tie breaks
it's gonna be a very intense round four
and uh the bar is
two ferocious side i've been uh looking
at that uh bar as well
and uh frozen duda they are tied before
this game three
so a lot of drama about to happen in the
uh miami arena yeah i'm talking about
drama i mean i'm just absolutely shocked
by this move i mean
that porn is by itself
no defense
why why move that pawn why on earth move
that pawn i don't understand it that
being said the computer does stockfish
there we see three move suggestions only
one move
takes advantage of this mistake from
white and that is for black's light
square bishop to park itself on the edge
of the board to be honest that's quite a
natural one the black king is coming
towards that white pawn i mean i think
yeah i mean you you want it your
opponent's moved to porn it's now on
unprotected it's protected pawn we try
to take it let's move our king let's
take it then we're pawn up with
why why why why this move yeah i don't
know
he was just scared of sitting there this
is actually a theme in the tournament as
well nobody wants to just sit there
passively and defend they want to be
active defenders and normally that's a
good thing but it has led to mistakes
and hans does find the best move yeah
they're freddie no mates there the f
pawn is just gonna drop
he is yeah the king's just gonna come
and take it that means hans he's gonna
be a pawn up he had that horrible
opening as well
and he's going to be a pawn up he's
going to have the two bishops he's got
all these little advantages
and if he can do something on the queen
side later he's probably going to be
winning this game yeah
and anish putting his knight to the side
of the board presumably he has some
ideas of jumping that knight to the f5
square but i mean just take a look at
this beautiful move you know it's
getting worse it is you know it's the
now the c4 pawn that's under attack and
if that one falls then more to come it's
like a pack of cards it's like a house
of cards right now one just flick uh one
of the pawns disappearing and the house
is going to collapse for giri how are
you even going to defend it you can't
you just have to go on the counter
attack yeah but even then
one move throughout it is just a one
move threat and you can defend against
that one very easily
it's really really bad news for anish
anish i mean he's going to be kicking
himself so much after this game i mean
he should have been winning really by
just keeping it under control then he he
had so many i think david put the nail
on the head indecisive he's been very
indecisive a couple of times and this
pawn push as well that was just a sign
of nerves
which uh made made another mistake and
you know the last game now is going to
be really tense um with hands having the
white pieces yeah so we attacked the
black bishop but look at black star
square bishop just defends everything
and okay this uh check from gary is he
really going after black spawns on that
side of the board with the white knight
looks like the wrong direction
i guess he has to he has to try
and now i mean the black king i would
just start taking that f pawn off the
board there we go black's king is going
to march into the center
black is it
essentially playing with a free piece an
extra piece
yup and you're going to be playing with
an extra pawn
yep um this one's just gone for gary
no chance and it's not just those kind
of indecision uh the indecisive moments
it's
every mistake has been trying to swap
the queens off trying to go passive
trying to force a draw it's playing for
a draw it just never works i've lost so
many games myself uh playing for a draw
i'll lose lots of games in the future
playing for a draw you just have to play
aggressive yeah you never played for
draw anymore david that's because i lost
too many games trying
against especially against strong
players or if i only needed that result
ironically here you know yeah he played
for a draw he made lots of passive
decisions but it was that porn move
right at the end that kind of was the
killer well no the losing blunder even
without that poor move he was in for a
load of suffering for
50 hundred moves of suffering so he kind
of maybe wanted to shorten that
suffering by taking a risk it's
understandable it was a mistake
but
i blame the early decisions swapping the
queens swapping the rooks
especially when you're facing the two
bishops i've said this many times like
when you're playing against two bishops
you need to accelerate the play you need
to keep pieces on the board the more
pieces get traded the stronger the
bishops become and black bishops
beautiful you know the good news about
this
surely we're going to get a hands
interview now
surely
i mean i think he's just threatening to
win a piece isn't he going to check
probably a very clever move but has
calculated this gary giving up his
knight
deflecting away the oh yeah he has
calculated it of course check the white
king driven away and next move the
knight falls hands takes the win wow
come back bye hans nimon he ties the
match against anish giri